Nos dicen: "Demuestra que, si una recta es
paralela a uno de los lados de un triángulo,
entonces divide los otros dos lados de forma
proporcional". Pausa el video y ve si puedes
resolver esto, y es posible que quieras aprovechar
este diagrama. Muy bien, así que trabajemos juntos
en esto. Vamos a analizar el diagrama. Aquí vemos
que el segmento ED es paralelo al segmento CD,
entonces podemos escribir esto: el segmento ED || al segmento CB, el
segmento ED es al que nos estamos refiriendo,
es una recta o segmento de recta paralela
a un lado del triángulo. Por lo que,
dado lo que sabemos y lo que está descrito
aquí en el diagrama, necesitamos una forma
de demostrar que esto divide los otros dos lados
de forma proporcional. Otra forma de decir esto es
que la razón entre el segmento que está de este
lado del segmento ED y el segmento que está del
otro lado del segmento ED, en uno de los lados del
triángulo original, va a ser la misma en los dos
lados que interseca el segmento ED; así que esta
es otra forma de decir que divide los otros dos
lados de forma proporcional. Si vemos este lado
del triángulo y tomamos la longitud del segmento
AE entre la longitud del segmento EC esto debe
ser igual a la longitud del segmento AD entre
la longitud del segmento DB. Esta afirmación que
acabo de escribir es equivalente a lo que subrayé
aquí con respecto a este triángulo. Una forma
en la que podemos resolver esto es establecer
semejanza entre el triángulo AED y el triángulo
ACB. ¿Cómo podemos hacer esto? Bueno, debido a
que estas dos rectas son paralelas, podemos ver
al segmento AC como una transversal que interseca
dos rectas paralelas, lo que nos dice que estos
dos ángulos correspondientes serán congruentes,
así que escribimos que el ángulo 1 es congruente
con el ángulo 3 (∠ 1 ≅ ∠ 3), y las razones porque
ambos son ángulos correspondientes lo escribo
abreviado para ahorrar espacio. Y también sabemos
que el ángulo 2 es congruente con el ángulo
4 por la misma razón, entonces ∠ 2 ≅ ∠ 4,
una vez más porque son ángulos correspondientes.
Esta vez tenemos una transversal diferente y los
ángulos correspondientes en donde una transversal
interseca dos rectas paralelas. Ahora, si ves el
triángulo AED y el triángulo ACB verás que tienen
dos conjuntos de ángulos correspondientes que son
congruentes, y si tienen dos conjuntos de ángulos
correspondientes esto significa que todos los
ángulos son congruentes. Y realmente podemos ver
esto aquí, aunque tener dos ángulos es suficiente,
en realidad tienes un tercero aquí, ya que
el ángulo BAC es común a ambos triángulos. Y
entonces podemos decir que el triángulo AED es
semejante al triángulo ACB (Δ AED ~ Δ ACB) por
semejanza ángulo ángulo; y luego, dado que
estos dos son semejantes, entonces podemos
establecer una proporción. Eso nos dice que
la razón entre la longitud del segmento AE y
todo este lado AC es igual a la razón entre la
longitud del segmento AD y la longitud de todo
el segmento AB. Esto implica que -voy a escribir
esto a la derecha para aprovechar el espacio-,
esto es lo mismo que la razón de AE / AC y AC es
igual a la longitud de AE más la longitud de EC,
y luego esto será igual a la longitud del
segmento AD entre la longitud del segmento AB,
y su longitud es la longitud del segmento
AD más la longitud del segmento DB. Ahora,
lo que tengo que resolver es cómo manipular
esto algebraicamente para obtener lo que tenemos
aquí. Entonces, una forma en que podría tratar de
simplificar esto es multiplicar de forma cruzada,
que es equivalente a multiplicar los dos lados
por ambos denominadores, y lo hemos explicado
en otros videos. Entonces esto será igual a la
longitud del segmento AE multiplicada por las
longitudes de AD + DB, y esto debe ser igual a la
longitud de AD multiplicada por AE más la longitud
del segmento EC. Y puedo distribuir esto por aquí:
tengo la longitud del segmento AE por la longitud
del segmento AD, más la longitud del segmento
AE por la longitud del segmento DB, es igual a
la longitud del segmento AD por la longitud del
segmento AE, más la longitud del segmento AD por
la longitud del segmento EC. Y veamos, ¿hay algo
que pueda simplificar aquí? Tenemos AE por AD en
ambos lados -permíteme restar AE por AD en
ambos lados-, y entonces sólo queda que esto
es igual a esto. Y permíteme reescribir esto
mejor: tengo que (AE) (DB) = (AD) (EC). estas
son todas las longitudes de segmentos. Ahora,
si dividimos ambos lados entre EC tendremos
una EC aquí y esto se cancelará, y luego,
si dividimos ambos lados entre DB, esto se
cancelará y obtendremos DB aquí. Entonces, si sólo
manipulamos algebraicamente lo que teníamos acá,
nos queda que la longitud del segmento AE
entre la longitud del segmento EC es igual a
la longitud del segmento AD entre la longitud del
segmento DB, la longitud del segmento AD entre la
longitud del segmento DB, que es exactamente lo
que queríamos demostrar: que esta recta aquí,
que es paralela a este lado de acá, divide
los otros dos lados proporcionalmente.